despite the terrifying upward trend in
coronavirus cases
and deaths many officials are still
reluctant to take action that could save
lives
carter evans is in twin falls idaho
where the numbers are
alarming carter good morning
good morning community spread here in
idaho is severe numbers from the covid
tracking project
suggest there are 85 thousand cases
statewide that basically means
two out of every five people tested in
idaho
are now positive for covet 19.
with hospitals across idaho nearing
capacity doctors worry about what will
happen
when there are no more beds we would be
in the
unimaginably bad situation of needing to
make decisions about who gets it
and who doesn't dr james souza is the
chief medical officer for st
luke's health system in boise if a heart
attack victim comes in
and the icu is full of covet patients
what do you do
we do our best and if one of those covid
patients
has a lower chance of survival we make
decisions about
who gets the bet how far away are you
from something like that
our modeling is suggesting that we may
be facing
that scenario in december
despite nearly 800 deaths idaho's
republican governor has resisted issuing
a mass mandate
a requirement some residents oppose all
they're trying to do is
control you everything you do is based
on the mask and the disease
and it's wrong with the u.s now
averaging about 160
000 new cases a day nearly three dozen
states now have a masked
mandate with kansas being the latest to
issue the order on wednesday
how we choose to respond can turn the
tide for our businesses
our hospitals and our schools but in
south dakota which is experiencing one
of the worst coveted outbreaks in the
country
republican governor christie gnome
reiterated her opposition to mandating
masks
even though the state's medical
association said tuesday it strongly
supports the move
i don't want to approach a policy or a
mandate
just looking to make people feel good
around the country
front line workers are concerned and
frustrated in nebraska more than
1700 health care workers signed a letter
pleading with people to wear masks
stating the life you save may be your
own
there's a sunny day on the other side
i'm way more interested in
cooperation than compliance so you're
saying
wear the mask social distance six feet
and you don't have to shut down the
economy
that's exactly what i'm saying
for doctors to begin deciding who gets a
bed and who doesn't the governor here in
idaho would have to declare what's
called a crisis
standard of care in the meantime with
hospitals inundated doctors are
concerned that patients
right now won't get the level of care
they need tony
all right carter thank you very much